about 5 16 on your friday morning yeah
we are just a couple of weeks into the
new school year but for high school
seniors all the way down to the youngest
pre-k kids it's never too early to think
about college
for the second year in a row the nevada
state treasurer's office is sponsoring
an all grades art contest with a top
prize of a thousand dollars in college
savings money and plenty of other awards
on the line
to help students focus on their futures
the theme of the contest is what do you
want to be when you grow up
a few of the winners from last year
paleontologist
artist and illustrator
any type of art's okay but entries
cannot be any bigger or smaller than a
regular old eight and a half by eleven
piece of paper
the contest started on monday entries
will be accepted until october 14th will
be a reception for the winners november
17th at the whitney library at trop and
nellis in the southeast valley got links
to the contest info and the online
version of this story on our website we
always want to know what's cool at
school if you know something let us know
cool at school under the community tab
on our website or just email cool at
school at eight newsnow dot com so again
pre-k kids not necessarily concerned
about college but their moms and dads
might say just go ahead and doodle
something right because you can get a
thousand dollars for your college fund
you betcha and did you say it's for
every grade there's a winner i believe
so wow that's fantastic and what a great
start for a college fund and you cannot
start saving too early and that's one of
the things they always tell moms and
dads yes yes i did i started pretty
early and i thought i was doing well and
we're doing okay but i could have
started even sooner
don't worry kids by the way whatever you
say you want to be when you grow up you
don't have to necessarily be there man
paleontologist is pretty cool